getting into a consulting firm like
mckinsey bc urbane is considered a quite
ambitious career goal for many people so
once you're in why the heck would you
decide to quit to move out again this is
exactly the topic i want to talk about
today welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich i'm a former strategy
consultant and i want to help you to
become successful in the first years of
your career so let's talk about leaving
a consulting firm like mckinsey and the
inspiration for this is a video that i
saw on the channel of miss angie lou
she's a rather new youtuber who's
creating videos about consulting related
topics as well and here's one video
about why did i choose to leave mckinsey
you see that i got already 10 000 views
which is quite a lot for a channel of
this size so do like many of her videos
encourage you to give her some love by
subscribing to our channel if you enjoy
this content as well so my plan for
today is to react to this video so i
already skipped forward to the part
where she starts talking about leaving
mckinsey what her reasons were and i
want to look into this with you and give
you my commentary on her points but i
think they are valid whether i made
experiences something like this as well
so without further ado let's get
into it
now be honest why not why is consulting
or mckenzie not the right career for me
well first of all i knew that the
lifestyle isn't for me the simplest way
to find out is the future me test so if
you are wondering the same just take a
look at the leadership in your same
company do you want to be like that
leader do you admire or enjoy the
lifestyle that he or she currently have
as for me yes the consulting lifestyle
was glamorous to a certain point however
whenever i look at the partners and
mckenzie their lifestyle i knew deeply
that that was not the life that i had in
mind
i think that's very valid right thinking
about the next best people in the
hierarchy your your leads your team
leads the leads of your team leads what
does their life look like what is their
career looking like and this is
something that you aspire to do and yeah
i think it's understandable if you look
at the partners how late they work how
busy they are how stressed they often
are and then think for yourself and
decide for yourself this is not a career
for you the thing is also fair to
recognize that even though maybe you
don't want to become a partner in a
consulting firm just starting and
consulting and working there for a
couple of years still might be a great
choice the truth probably is that only a
very small minority of all the people
who join consulting already decide for
themselves that yes they want to pursue
this career until they become partner
it's rather common for people to say i
just want to do this job for two three
or four years for all the learnings and
then at some point i can still
reevaluate whether i do actually like it
indeed but i do want to continue what i
want to move out
i did not want to travel to different
cities every other day i did not want to
have to work until 2am every single day
i also did not want to be away from my
family for most of the week
i think this is also very valid i made
another video talking about what the
typical work week of the consultant
looks like i will link it somewhere
above here she talks about working until
2am every single day my experience was
not like that you needed to work until
2m every single day but there surely
were individual projects where working
until 2 a.m on a regular basis wouldn't
be rare right so you need to be ready
that things like this happen that yes
you might need to work out significantly
after midnight not all the time but at
least on selected days and sometimes
also for several weeks on certain
projects
now second the constant pressure and
urgency as you may know consulting
projects are typically short and very
challenging and most likely they're not
the team is always understaffed that's
probably how consulting companies make
such a high margin per project
yeah so she says at vanessa correctly
that she believes the pressure is so
high because the teams are understaffed
not sure i would 100 agree with that so
i mean we just talked about that yes
there is a lot of work lots of things of
ours that you need to put in but i don't
necessarily agree that just only if you
would have one or two or three
additional people staffed on the team
that this would necessarily make
everyone's life easier so in a like an
mbb environment if you work for a
consulting firm like bcg or bain a
typical team size would be two to five
people including a project lead so the
team sizes are quite small i would argue
that the main reason why hours can be
sometimes quite long is that just during
the regular work day so from 9 00 a.m to
6 p.m or so usually spend so much time
with a client conducting interviews
talking to them looking at some data
that you get they just don't really have
time to then sympathize all these
insights recreate your documents do the
actual work that you need to do to
really make progress on on the project
which is why this is often than what you
end up doing after 6 pm in the evening
once the clients are not in the office
anymore
so therefore everything becomes a
priority there are so many nights where
i would remember uh the engagement
manager would say to me that this is a
priority that you must finish before
tomorrow so that's why typically we work
12 to 15 hour days or even more and for
me as an example i actually have
experienced panic attacks during
so let's talk about that when everything
becoming a priority so yes for sure this
does happen so someone pushing you to
still in the evening maybe even at night
complete something for the next day
i did make the experience those that
especially in the first years like after
one or two years once you've learned the
job a little bit like earned your ropes
you start also learning a little bit
this game of pushing back in the right
way as a young consultant as an
associate i think if you're quite junior
in your first half year or in your first
year you feel like you just need to do
everything that you're being asked to do
right everything just say yes of course
i need to do this and so on even though
this means really working really late
there are some tips and tricks and
techniques that you just pick up over
time to manage this in a bit better way
for you if you're interested to learn
more about that just let me know in the
comments i might create some additional
videos on this very topic several of my
projects where i remember one weekend i
was actually flying back to the project
and as the plane was touching down i
just get more and more nervous where i
could not even hear the sound of my
gmail i kid you not i literally had to
delete the gmail app in order for myself
to actually calm down the third piece
the exhaust so this this thing of panic
attacks really feeling intense pressure
really not being able to handle it
anymore i mean here surely you know
people are different people react to
stress in a different way i would
consider myself probably quite resistant
to stress but even myself i really had
also very very let's say dark days or
dark weeks right in these situations in
consulting i mean i remember being on
one project i just felt under so much
pressure my head was about to explode
this is at least how i felt like that i
locked myself into a toilet cabin right
at one of the clients places and i
remember having a meditation app on my
phone so i put on some headphones and i
was just trying to listen to this
meditation app for like 15 minutes or so
just to
calm down a little bit because it just
couldn't bear anymore i mean pressure
can be intense also here over time this
is an area where you will just need to
learn some techniques on how to handle
that and how to also dissociate yourself
to some extent to really the work to
what's going on the whole day but i mean
these are things that can be like a very
significant burden on some people
depending on how you react to these
things exhaustion from constant travel
and overworking if you were asking me
back then what did you do on the weekend
i would probably tell you
sleep
i would sleep until 11 wake up for a
quick lunch and then keep sleeping or
take a nap so that i can recover from
the previous week and have enough energy
for the week after i also remember that
i hate it hate it hate it monday morning
yes i know mondays are really hard but
it's even harder when you have to wake
up at 4am every monday morning to catch
the first flight out also you'll work
until midnight pretty much every day of
the week and because
i mean this is probably just true right
especially for these large strategy
consulting firms bcg bain and so on i
mean you will just need to work quite
late you will often have these weekends
where you just sleep because you need to
recover from the week i mean frankly i
think monday tuesday wednesday are
probably the hardest days at least in
the you know pre-public health crisis
situation where you just were traveling
all the time because monday morning
indeed as the lady just told us you will
wake up often at 4am 5am to get to the
airport get the first flight out then
monday evening tuesday evening wednesday
evening is going to be quite late hours
then on thursday evening you might fly
back this day is already a little bit
lighter because then usually at eight
nine pm you will be at home and then
some emails but not that significant
work anymore at least most of the days
and then friday usually you will be out
of the office at 5 00 p.m or 6 p.m so
nothing too crazy but then many people
will need some time to recover on the
weekends indeed
of all of this i actually developed this
skill to be able to fall asleep um or
work anytime and anywhere back up the
car easy
on the plane no problem
on the stairs no challenge at all
standing in line yeah i got that too the
third piece yeah it's also true right
you really just developed this habit of
just working all the time and to some
extent i always wondered whether this
was just also like just the group
pressure everyone else was doing it so
you felt you needed to do it as well but
on the other hand it surely was also
part of you know everything that you
could get done earlier just was more
time you had in the evening for yourself
potentially to sleep so this is just
what you did i remember riding a cab
once being in a taxi once with a couple
of other team colleagues and then the
cab driver was asking us so you guys
must be from this consulting firm right
we just looked at us and like why like
how do you know how do you come up with
this and then the cab driver was saying
well you guys from this firm you are the
only one so always open your laptops in
the cab and just continue working this
is that i really wanted more hands-on
experience yes consulting companies will
tell you that they do implementation
work as well but typically that's not
true implementation work we still stay
very high level and very strategic but
it's also due to the nature of our work
typically it is unlikely for you to
staff a consultant for you know years to
be able to finish implementation project
but i really craved that hands-on
experience i really really really wanted
to be able to build something on my own
something that i can be proud of and i
thought that the best way to do that is
to leave consulting enjoying startups
i mean to some extent i think it's right
depends also of course which specific
consulting firm you join i mean some are
more heavy on the strategy side some are
more heavier on the implementation side
but also in a strategy consulting firm i
did work on several projects which were
close very close to impact i mean a good
example i think is always procurement
consulting and procurement consulting
really often just work with a client up
until the point where you really realize
certain savings with your suppliers in
direct and direct material so depends a
bit on the type of project but of course
for sure what you will not do as a
consultant is to take operative
responsibility and last but not least to
be out of
the bubble consultants always have the
reputation of being the smart one but
also the arrogant and the self-centered
one i'm not saying that everyone in
consulting is like that but i did find
myself for a period of time i was a
little bit like that and i felt that i
lost my humility for a while well it is
because the environment that we're so
here i'd say i cannot really agree i
really cannot say that consultants were
self-centered or arrogant or anything
like that so i met so many extremely
humble people while working consulting
they were just so kind so friendly so
empathetic surely as in most of these
environments they're always also people
are not so nice or not so great people
do not really enjoy hanging out with but
not to say their consultants in general
were so arrogant and so on that at least
in my humble experience this is not what
i saw there wherein everyone around us
are prioritizing us our work over
everything else everything that we do
becomes a priority i mean think about
the glamorous lifestyle right we
literally had a team to book cars and
tickets and flights for us so i was
constantly living in this bubble a
bubble that has a reality distortion
field a bubble that actually separates
us from the real world a world
yeah i agree i mean these support teams
surely exist and this is though i would
argue not just out of arrogance but just
all of the necessities so you will just
be able to just reschedule flights all
the time i mean almost every friday we
took especially on thursday got
rescheduled at least once that was super
common sometimes you would even
reschedule it after the plane already
departed right i mean then it's probably
a question of personal character whether
you let this get to you get into your
head too much or not well that makes us
the oblivious and self-centered and
arrogant pricks that we used to hate i
really need to get out before it's too
late well this is my story if you're
interested in exploring a career in
consulting i hope my story can give you
a more holistic picture of what a career
yeah i think these were the points i
mean i provided my commentary would of
course be interested what do you think
about that whether this matches your
experience in consulting or not also
just to be not misunderstood my
commentary was not about any specific
form also necessarily of any of my past
employers but just my general
understanding of what it's like to work
in consulting also in other firms and
why some of these things really sounded
dark and maybe not so nice i still
believe that consulting is one of the
best career choices for aspiring young
business graduates i made plenty of
videos on this topic as well i just do
think it is important of course to be
aware of what you are getting yourself
into because these are realities that
you will face and many of these
consulting firms and just would not be
fair to not know about these things when
you would decide to start your career
and consulting so if you took any value
out of this video at all please hit the
like button for the youtube algorithm
subscribe and also put on the
notifications to stay informed on all
the videos that are great my name is
heinrich i release new videos every
single saturday big big thanks to all
the members of this channel for
supporting i will link some videos left
and right to me where you can continue
your learning journey on this channel
looking forward to talking to you soon
again bye bye heinel here